mittlerweile gibt es in der medizin
einen knochenersatz aus glas der sich so
schnell auflöst wie der knochen
nachwächst dieses glassubstrat ist
tatsächlich so gebaut dass nie eine
lücke entsteht windräder wären ohne glas
auch nicht denkbar verstärkungsfasern
aus glas machen es überhaupt erst
möglich rotorblätter mit 80 oder 90
metern länge zu bauen glas ist mega
spannend und cool aber natürlich gibt es
auch ein problem
wie kann so ein festes material so
schnell zerbrechen mit welcher
geschwindigkeit bricht glas eigentlich
genau und was ist glas überhaupt das ist
tatsächlich gar nicht so leicht zu
beantworten aber ich versuche heute
trotzdem mit einer
hochgeschwindigkeitskamera und 460.000
bildern pro sekunde
[Musik]
was ist glas glas ist einerseits die
scheibe von meinem smartphone glas ist
aber auch die leitung die das internet
zu dir nach hause bringt und glas ist
der grund warum ich gerade diesen text
hier sprechen kann ohne die augen von
der kamera zu nehmen glas ist also ein
werkstoff ein material mit eigenschaften
die es verdammt wichtig für uns machen
glas ist durchsichtig wetter resistent
und fest ok super damit sind ja
eigentlich alle fragen beantwortet oder
viel leckeres zuschauern und bleibt
immer neugierig
okay ganz so einfach ist das natürlich
dann doch nicht denn was genau glas ist
kommt auf die perspektive an ist glas
fest flüssig oder sogar eher einen
aggregatzustand nun ja tatsächlich ist
es fast all diese dinge gleichzeitig man
kann glas als werkstoff betrachten kann
glas allerdings auch aus thermo
dynamischer sicht sehen und hier wird es
etwas komplizierter denn geht es darum
den zustand eines stoffes zu beschreiben
gibt es erstmal die drei klassischen
aggregatzustände gasförmig flüssig und
fest ein beispiel über 100 grad
verdampft wasser wenn es dann kälter
wird würdest du wassern also flüssig und
bei null grad angekommen wurde es fest
zuerst bilden sich kristalle und standen
haben wir plötzlich eis wenn du jetzt
fragen warum es auf einmal um wasser
geht der letzte punkt ist tatsächlich
sehr entscheidend für glas bei einem
festen aggregatzustand spricht man
normalerweise von einem kristallinen
zustand haus es geht um glas denn aus
einem thermodynamischen startpunkt ist
glas quasi ein vierter aggregatzustand
und das hat mit der herstellung zu tun
welche zutaten man für glas braucht das
kommt ganz darauf an welches glas ich
produzieren möchte heutzutage macht kalk
natron glas circa 90 prozent des glases
weltweit aus und das besteht aus
siliziumdioxid natrium oxid und calcium
oxid das habt ihr gerade zufällig nicht
im schrank zu hause kein problem das
geht auch sehr viel einfacher sand kalk
und natrium karbonat dass man auch als
was so luck and funktionieren genauso
gut aber spätestens dann wird es
schwierig denn die vierte zutat ist
hitze in glas herzustellen braucht die
etwa 1000 grad einfach so zu hause ein
neues fenster herstellen ist also leider
keine option trotzdem haben es menschen
schon vor 4000 jahren geschafft erstens
so heiße feuer zu machen und zweitens
dabei wahrscheinlich zufällig glas zu
das stichwort sind hier tongefäße um die
nämlich zu brennen brauchte es super
heiße öfen zufälligerweise waren da
wahrscheinlich auch soda haltige asche
und ein kalk und sand haltiger boden die
dafür gesorgt haben dass unter den höfen
kleine glas klumpen entstanden sind
unter dieser enormen hitze schmelzen die
zutaten da uns 1000 grad heißer
smartphone bildschirm aber herzlich
wenig bringt muss das ganze natürlich
auch abgekühlt werden und hier passiert
etwas entscheidendes glas muss nämlich
super schnell gekühlt werden denn dabei
hat der stoff nicht die möglichkeit sich
in kristallen anzuordnen
so bekommt man ein material mit einer
nicht kristallinen struktur und zwar
glas ohne kristalline struktur lässt
sich hier auch nicht direkt von einem
festen material sprechen im
physikalischen sinne wäre es genauer
wenn man glas eine unterkühlte
flüssigkeit nennt und das krasse ist man
könnte mit dieser methode rein
theoretisch aus jedem element einen glas
herstellen dafür muss man es auf dem weg
von flüssig nach fest einfach nur
schnell genug abkühlen so dass sich das
material nicht kristallisieren kann
[Musik]
ohne diesen besonderen aggregatzustand
zwischen fest und flüssig wäre glas auch
nicht glas würde es kristallisieren habe
ich kein gras mehr und die üblichen
eigenschaften von glas gehen verloren
kristalle haben zum beispiel korngrenzen
zueinander und an den grenzen findet
lichtbrechung stadt so wäre glas zum
beispiel nicht mehr durchsichtig
trotzdem gibt es natürlich glas milch
materialien die nicht kristallines glas
mit einem festen kristallinen werkstoff
vereinen nur eine herdplatte zum
beispiel weil sich hier glas mit anderen
phasen vermischt bekomme ich
eigenschaften die einerseits glasig und
andererseits kristallinen sind ein
weiteres beispiel ist das neue iphone 12
das hat ja einst ramic schielt das
verbindet die eigenschaften von sowohl
glas als auch keramik es ist
gleichzeitig durchsichtig soll jetzt
aber bis zu viermal stoß fester sein
noch ein anderes beispiel sind kamin
sicht schreiben die werden regelmäßig
einem sehr starken terrorschock
ausgesetzt gehen dabei aber nicht kaputt
ok lassen wir das mal eben zusammen
platz kann man als werkstoff betrachten
man kann glas aber auch aus
thermodynamische perspektive als
unterkühlte flüssigkeit kategorisieren
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht wieso
hat ein glas keine eigenschaften die wie
eine flüssigkeit sind passiert fühlt
sich alles andere als flüssig an
glücklicherweise kann man glas noch aus
einer dritten mechanischen perspektive
betrachten denn glas ist keine
flüssigkeit im mechanischen glas fließt
nicht die viskosität ist so hoch dass
keine atom oder molekül bewegungen die
bei einer flüssigkeit stattfinden können
zumindest nicht in den menschlichen
zeiträumen die wir uns vorstellen können
[Musik]
ok kommen wir mal zurück ursprünglichen
frage zurück was zur hölle ist
eigentlich glas wir schon bemerkt habt
kommt das eben auf die perspektive an
simpel gesagt glas ist glas es ist seine
eigene kategorie wenn ihr aber auf
nummer sicher gehen wollt dann wäre es
am besten von einer unterkühlten
flüssigkeit zu sprechen die nicht mehr
in einem thermodynamischen gleichgewicht
deswegen nicht kristallin aber trotzdem
fest ist hilft uns diese definition auch
zu verstehen warum glas bericht wie es
bericht ich meine eine nicht geordnete
struktur hat sich ja irgendwie sehr
instabile an oder nein denn wenn man
materialien brechen sieht unterscheidet
man zwischen diktieren und spuren
brüchen der unterschied liegt in der
kristallstruktur metalle zum beispiel
haben versetzungen die übereinander
wegbleiben subtilität stellt euch
rollläden vor die wir aus einer
zusammenhängenden platz bebauen wenn ich
die rollläden hochfahren will müssen
sich diese platten jahr auf rollen also
biegen und das wird schwierig irgendwann
wird die krümmung so groß dass die
platte bricht deswegen haben rollläden
unterschiedliche lamellen die durch
scharniere miteinander verbunden sind so
dass das ganze wieder eingeklappt werden
kann das ist basi was die versetzung
linien in einem metall ermöglichen
aktives verhalten heißt im endeffekt
dass sich materialien verformen oder
biegen lassen bevor sie brechen je höher
die duc thi thet ist desto besser lassen
sie sich verformen gold zum beispiel ist
so etwas wie das paradebeispiel für die
aktivität das edelmetall lässt sich
nämlich bis auf wenige atomlagen
verformen und deswegen kann man das als
blattgold überall drauf machen und farbe
glas wäre in diesem fall die rolllade
ohne versetzungen denn glas ist genau
wie zum beispiel beton oder keramik
sprügel das heißt anstatt sich wie durch
viele materialien unter belastungen zu
biegen brechen sie einfach und das habe
ich und bestimmt auch viele von euch
schon schmerzhaft selber erlebt
wenn auch ein smartphone glas eine große
kraft ausgeübt wird dann sieht man spur
das material in action bei einem
aufprall kann sich das glas nicht
verbiegen so dass nur eine beute zurück
bleibt das würde ein teil zum beispiel
aluminium machen glas zerspringt und
wenn ihr euch fragt wie das hier
passiert ist dann abonniert am besten
den kanal denn das zeigen wir euch in
einem der nächsten videos in slow motion
aber erst mal zurück zum thema das glas
von so einem smartphone ist tatsächlich
ein richtiger hightech rohstoff es
funktioniert als touchscreen ist leicht
verändert die farben des bildschirms
fast gar nicht und hat eine dicke von
gerade mal 20 bis 50 mikrometern das ist
ungefähr so dick wie ein menschliches
haar hier wird das äußerste aus glas
herausgeholt aber es bleibt leider glas
und glas zerbricht nun mal wenn das
bricht dann passiert das super schnell
wie schnell naja so schnell dass ihr
euch die scherben in der küche ersparen
könnte wenn ich das selber herausfinden
wollte glas nicht so schnell dass wir es
unmöglich mit dem menschlichen auge
beobachten können selbst unsere high
speed aufnahme vom anfang des videos
kann man nicht wirklich sehen wie das
glas zerbricht in einem bild ist das
glas noch heile und direkt im nächsten
ist es kaputt um zu sehen wie glas
bricht bräuchte man schon eine verdammt
teure hochgeschwindigkeitskamera die
schafft bis zu mehrere hundert tausend
bilder pro sekunde aufzunehmen man
müsste einen ganzen dreh organisieren
mit verdammt vielen scheinwerfern denn
oder so einfach und bildrate film zu
können muss es superheld sein und das
alles mal eben so zu organisieren nur um
zu schauen wie schnell glas bricht das
wäre schon ein bisschen übertrieben oder
[Musik]
spoiler alert glas bericht sehr schnell
aber um genau herauszufinden wie schnell
es bricht wollen wir heute mal ein
kleines experiment machen dafür haben
wir eine highspeed kamera dabei nämlich
die fans mv 25 12 ein unglaublich
krasses einer kameradin kann bis zu
650.000 bilder pro sekunde in farbe
aufnehmen wir haben jetzt eingestellt
auf 460.000 bilder pro sekunde und
selbst das wird wahrscheinlich gerade so
ausreichend denn wir wollen halt sehen
wie glas bricht unglaublich schnell und
wir haben ausgerechnet dass wir auf
unserem halben meter glas wahrscheinlich
ein unter einer sekunde aufnehmen werden
wenn wir tatsächlich 64.000 bildern pro
sekunde aufnehmen werden dass das eine
und obwohl heute ist sehr hell ist und
sehr heiß ist wollen wir trotzdem noch
zusätzliches licht wir haben hier in led
strahler an led strahler mit einem
kilowatt power und selbst das wird
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so
unglaublich hell sein denn das problem
ist dass wir eine belichtungszeit von
nur einer mikrosekunde haben eine
mikrosekunde ist sehr kurz hat aber den
vorteil dass wir dann keine
bewegungsunschärfe haben wünscht mir
glück denn wir haben nur eine
glasscheibe und wenn die kaputt ist
haben wir keine zweite mehr ich habe
dieses professionelle glas verbrechens
gerät hier bei mir und ich werde jetzt
einfach mal drauf hauen wenn alle bereit
sind
[Musik]
ich mach's mit einem schritt anlauf alle
bereit
[Musik]
so dämlich
ok also erstmal hier vielen lieben dank
an rainer schild dass wir uns ermöglicht
haben so eine wirklich coole und unter
uns auch verdammt teure kamera zu
besorgen das sieht jetzt zwar sehr
verpixelt aus ist es auch aber das liegt
daran dass es mit
460.000 bildern pro sekunde aufgenommen
wurde nur zum vergleich die besten
consumer kameras höheren spätestens
irgendwann mal 1000 bildern pro sekunde
auf und sind deswegen dann auch schon
ausgelegt auf high speed also 460.000
wirklich viel und dass man perspektive
zu setzen wir spielen das sie gerade mit
25 bildern pro sekunde ab was wir aber
eigentlich damit 460.000 bildern pro
sekunde aufgenommen haben wenn man sich
mit dieser kamera und diesen
einstellungen etwas anschauen möchte was
in einer sekunde passiert dann dauert
das über fünf stunden also wenn ich das
auch nicht mehr was von jetzt bis jetzt
geht und dann schaue ich mir das an
dieser timeline jahr an dann dauert es
fünf stunden im vergleich mit 1000
bildern pro sekunde auch dass nur 40
sekunden okay aber wie schnell bricht
jetzt glas an den markierungen die wir
gemacht haben kann man immer ganz nah
erkennen wo die scheibe zu welchem
zeitpunkt schon gebrochen ist und dann
zählen wir einfach wie viele einzelne
bilder es dauert bis der bruch von einer
markierung bis zur nächsten und das um 5
cm weit gekommen ist es kommen einfach
mal machen hier auf der linken seite da
ist der bruch ungefähr ist ein bisschen
schwierig zu erkennen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 müller und um von diesem
frames also bildern auf die echte
geschwindigkeit des bruchs bekommen
teilen wir eine sekunde durch 460.000
dann jedes bild steht ja für eine 460
tausendstelsekunde das multiplizieren
wir dann mit der anzahl der bilder also
13 und kommen auf achtung
0,00 0 0 28 26 sekunden pro 5 cm etwas
komischer einheit da man das ganze nicht
so gut erkennen kann weil die auflösung
ja wie gesagt nicht so super gut ist
haben wir das mal in alle richtungen uns
angeschaut und dem mittelwert genommen
da brauchen wir so 14 bis 15 frames pro
5 cm und wenn man das alles mit geld und
um rechnet in einer etwas bekanntere
einheit dann kommen wir auf
5940 kilometer pro stunde die diese
spezielle glas unter diesen speziellen
bedingungen zerbrochen ist okay das ist
ziemlich schnell oder und dass meine
perspektive zu setzen das ist mehr als
fünfmal so schnell wie ein airbus a380
fliegt und mehr als doppelt so schnell
wie die concorde von london nach new
york bräuchte man wenn man einen
fiktiven glasbruch antrieb hätte weniger
als eine stunde die welt könnten wir in
gerade mal sechs stunden und 45 minuten
umrunden was mit einem normalen flugzeug
fast 34 stunden dauert das zeigt finde
ich wie krass schnell glas zerbricht
weil glas einfach keine andere
möglichkeit hat sich auch mal ein
bisschen zu verbiegen muss es
zerspringen und wie sicher so ein
display schutz ist das testen mit einem
der nächsten videos auf dieselbe art und
weise wie wir dieses sicherheitsglas
hier auf die probe gestellt haben mit
einem hammer wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen wollt dann klickt jetzt gerne
abonnieren das hilft unsere kanal weiter
das wäre echt hammer ansonsten immer
viel nacktes zuschauern und bleibt
neugierig erster blick
es ist so schlecht oder gut sitzt